residentes del edificio 22 bajen a
hacerse la prueba pcr las autoridades
chinas lanzaron una nueva ronda de
pruebas masivas en shanghai beijing y
xian después de un repunte de contagios
por kobe 19 y algunos ciudadanos han
reportado haber recibido raciones de
comida del gobierno un retroceso
respecto al largo confinamiento que
vivieron el mes pasado la gente ya no
tiene miedo del cbit sino de quedarse
encerrada en su casa el encierro de la
capital económica del país asiático en
primavera provocó inusuales protestas
contra la dura aplicación del gobierno
que dejó a muchos residentes con
dificultades para acceder a los
alimentos y los servicios médicos y
envío a miles de personas a centros de
cuarentena una situación que podría
repetirse
nos siguen encerrando yo trabajaba aquí
tenía mi propio negocio pero por culpa
del cob y nuestro negocio ha ido mal y
no quiero seguir atrapada en un sitio no
tengo libertad
entretanto en beijing los residentes que
quieran entrar en una serie de lugares
públicos tendrán que mostrar una prueba
de vacunación a partir del lunes es la
primera vez que china impone un mandato
de vacunación contra el coronavirus